do you know what an mba is and how it is
different from other business master
degrees mba stands for master of
business administration what's special
about it is that it's a post experience
degree this means that you need to have
work experience in order to be admitted
on average the typical mba candidate
will have four to five years of work
experience but if you come from a
so-called accelerated career track like
consulting or banking two to three years
might be fine as well mbas are supposed
to be much more hands-on and practical
the more traditional academic master
degrees i completed an mba from insead
we for instance had a negotiation course
with a police hostage negotiator we also
conducted field trips to china or the
silicon valley to talk to vcs talk to
investors talk to startups to get
first-hand insights so what would be
like to start a business in these
regions an mba can be a transformative
experience for you though the downside
is the cost leading mba programs like
harvard stanford wharton will charge you
high five digit or even six digit study
fees per year follow for more career
insights